Game of Thrones so it's all done now
yeah which must be for you such a relief
it is nice it is nice I've been keeping
in these spoilers for so many years and
I can finally say goodbye to ya because
that video kind of went viral of Jessica
trying to guess what was gonna happen in
the last episode how much did you get
how much did you get right
not very much Queen Eleanor's you said
oh I haven't seen any of it you haven't
seen any of the series I haven't seen
any of the series by the time you get I
know but I like to wait for these things
to end and same binge oh yeah I don't
like to wait for the next season no
that's too long
otherwise you're waiting ten years seven
years I know but now Jessica's not the
only big fan because this is this your
husband was this post meeting you or was
this before me to you when this is post
meeting me I actually picked out the
costume for him and I did his hair yeah
I thought that's how he wooed you yeah
doesn't even gorgeous was it Halloween
at least it was hollow okay that's
something yes
but here's the thing you were in that
show since you were 13 13 and I mean
obviously you know now I'm 15 you know
we all get one childhood and that was
yours was on that show and looking back
on it now is there any sense of it you
know you feel like you missed out do you
bump into kids from school and kind of
think Oh or you just are you pleased it
was Game of Thrones that university
experience definitely I wish I'd kind of
you know been able to go out and drink a
lot and like throw up in the middle of
the club and not get pictured doing it
so now be a little more careful I have
to do it in the toilet sorry hence the
blonde hair no you're good tonight being
boys oh yeah no I I'm happy with my game
with friends experience I I'm I I don't
feel like I miss down too much
[Music]